oder nicht richtig
[Musik]
lecker finger von euro wollte sich der
boden das richtige wort ist war richtig
lecker
[Musik]
heiße sommer wir machen heute einen
carrot cake mit cheesecake in drin also
eine art rückblick kuchen mit käsekuchen
auf englisch etwas besser und ich habe
mir gedacht ich hab zwar hätten schon
ramadan deko hing aber ich würde auch
gerne mal was für ostern machen ich
glaube mehr multikulti geht gar nicht
und dafür mache ich jetzt zuallererst
einen teig so einen schönen saftigen
teig mit möhren ich schreibe euch wie
immer alle ganz schön und mengenangaben
unten in die infobox und ich starte
jetzt in meiner mutter übrigens ja es
ist ein kaufland placement wie man sehen
kann aber ihr wisst ja dass wir in kauf
ein ganz enger partnerschaft sind und
auf dem kaufland kanal ist von mir eine
richtig schöne ostertor online gigant
kann sie euch gerne am ende des videos
verlinken dann könnt ihr euch die auch
mal anschauen so bei der butter ist es
halt wichtig dass die zimmertemperatur
hat ihr könnt sie zwei drei stunden
vorher aus dem kühlschrank nimmt ich
habe da ein bisschen verpennt heute und
das nicht mehr gemacht aber ich habe
gerade in die sonne gestellt und das
sollte eigentlich funktionieren die wird
jetzt zusammen mit zucker und vanille
extrakt drei minuten lang schön cremig
geschlagen
[Musik]
zum teil habe ich jetzt noch die eier
eingerührt wichtig ist dass wir das
wirklichen nacheinander macht also jedes
ein brauch so 20 30 sekunden bis alles
schön vermengt ist und dann kommt erst
das nächste reiht sohn jetzt mache ich
aber erstmal weiter mit den möhren ich
muss eigentlich so früh ja gar kein fan
von karotten meine mutter hat ihn früher
mal ganz gerne gemacht und ich war immer
so abgetötet als kind war ich mittendrin
aber das macht den teig so saftig und
man schmeckt jetzt nicht wirklich möhren
raus als wenn man sie jetzt so essen
würde sondern es ist einfach das sein
was saftig und lecker also wer das noch
nicht ausprobiert hat sollte das
unbedingt mal nachholen so ich mache
jetzt so dass ich die natürlich erst mal
hier
ich habe jetzt hier auch eine
küchenwaage damit die schön abbiegen
kann wieviel karotte da jetzt rein kommt
dann nehmt euch einfach hier so eine
reibe und treibt das direkt dran
[Musik]
die karotten sind vorbereitet die
brauchen aber gleich erst jetzt machen
wir weiter mit dem trockenen zutaten
dadurch mehl und backpulver und main sid
wenn ich jetzt einfach dazu sehen mich
könnt ihr dann auch schon dazu tun und
dann kommen sie nur noch die möhren dazu
und wenn die mit etwas zimt
[Musik]
so kuchen masse ist fertig wir machen
weiter mit der cheesecake masse die geht
auch ganz schnell ich nehme jetzt hier
schon mal gefragt gibt auf dem eine
schüssel diesmal nämlich auch nur noch
einen schneebesen wie soll noch gar
nicht so viel rühren sondern nur so
lange wie notwendig da kommt dann gleich
noch ein ei für die bindung dazu und
außerdem noch speisestärke ein bisschen
zucker vanille extrakt und wenn ihr mögt
den abrieb einer bio zitrone dies jetzt
sehr groß da nehme ich jetzt nur den
halben aber ich finde es gibt noch mal
so schön frische kick
[Musik]
so tief machst du das jetzt auch verdi
und wir können das ganze befüllt ich
habe jetzt hier meine längliche meiner
eckige springform und da gebe ich jetzt
die nicht die hälfte ein bisschen mehr
als die hälfte von karotten teig rein
und wir wollen ja die cheesecake masse
quasi da drin so als kern verstecken
daher könnt ihr auf jeden fall auch so
ein bisschen am rand entlang und dann
gebe ich gleich einfach die komplette
cheesecake masse in die mitte und decke
noch mal mit karotten teig ab und dann
kommt auch schon in den backofen 180
grad ober und unterhitze und die
backzeit verrate ich euch gleich beim
letzten mal nicht aufgeschrieben glaube
es waren fünf 40 oder 50 minuten aber
ich schaue ich noch mal
[Musik]
noch ein ganz ganz wichtiger tipp
verteilt die karotten masse später für
den abschluss so punktuell also wirklich
immer so hier und da ein bisschen weil
wenn ihr alles auf einem fleck verteilt
da wird es sehr sehr schwierig das zu
verstreichen und die gestik massa schön
zu bedecken und so funktioniert das
einfacher da noch so ganz grob glatt
verstreichen und dann dürfen wir auch
schon backen
[Musik]
45 minuten hat das ganze jetzt bei mir
gebraucht und ich habe das jetzt
abgedeckt lass es auch nochmal abkühlen
aber ich kann euch ja schon mal den bus
verraten der funktionierte ist mich ganz
einfach wir brauchen nur drei zutaten
mascarpone braunen zucker der ist dann
so durch unsere schöne karamell ich und
ein bisschen vanille extrakt und das
ganze nur kurz verrühren also die
mascarpone sollten jetzt nicht zu lange
verrühren und dann gebe ich das einfach
als gross oben drüber und entweder ist
das ist euer fertiger kuchen das ganze
jahr über oder ihr möchtet ihnen für
ostern schmücken dann nehmt ihr einfach
noch teurer man bei kaufen was da so ein
sortiment gibt da gibt es ja ganz viele
eier entweder tokio oder einfach schöne
bunte eier ich glaube ich ihnen heute
bunte und dann verziert ihr das ganze
dann ist es auch schon fertig
[Musik]
wo der nicht richtig
dass in traunreut eine neue geschäfte
des geborenen uhr das ist mein traum so
wie
hunderte andere sun ab und so ist der
nächste tag weil er solche fotos
nachfolger wurde dass ich auch hier bin
habe ich gesehen
was ist das eigentlich das ist ja
rückblick kuchen oder wie ich gerne geld
cache mit
gestik in brandmaker fläche die die was
gefunden hat ist und ich durch
bedrohungen da kommt in der mitte des
skis klären ist da etwas fester kuchen
aber habe das schmeckt auch er ist fest
da ist aber sagte ich so oft ich bin
echt lecker es ist wirklich ein fester
und saftiger bürger eines beweises
einmal hier war kommt durch kein problem
das ist kein normaler boden das mache
ich ja das ist kein normaler bizkit
wohnhäuser und nun habe ich übrigens
nachher business blüten einfach drauf
gemacht weil sonst so nackig und mit den
eiern richtig oster feeling richtig
schön aber das ganze jahr über ohne ja
also einstecken und mit carrot cake
verbindung deswegen wollte ich den boden
das richtige war richtig lecker also wie
kannst du komponenten endlich gut
zusammen sind wir haben schwärmt ihr
müsst sie echt nachmachen heute noch
machen würde also sagen dass es nicht
nur so damit es damit gesagt ja die mine
ist ob ich so leid ich mich wirklich wie
komme ich glaube eine technisch sehr
viel kürzer wenn wir sagen nur
mutterkuchen in acht von zehn objekte
ist echt sehr sehr lecker vom von 10
franken das
kommando das ist der grund warum ich
aber wirklich darauf nehme ich kriege es
auch anrufe ich mich jetzt von euch
wünsche euch wie gesagt ganz viel fasst
nachmachen alle genauen mengenangaben
allem ein videos hier unten in der
infobox das ist das letzte video von
ramadan eine von ostern direkt auf
graumann ist anteiligen auf jeden fall
aber integration genau diese integration
an in der während der hammer jetzt jeden
zweiten tag ein neues rezept video also
wahrscheinlich unbedingt einen ersten
tagen sogar direkt jeden tag im video
aber als die glocke aktiven bekommt der
alles mit und dann würde ich mal sagen
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]